see ya
[Applause]
persona 5 is a game overflowing with
style from bold menus that leap off the
screen to the pop and lock of scene
transitions that carry the player around
a colorful Tokyo it's a game about
youthful exuberance and the power that
lies within it but its beauty isn't just
skin deep persona fives gameplay systems
evolve and coalesce over with 80 plus
hours to deliver a confidently executed
role-playing experience that is not only
satisfying but worth the almost
decade-long wait since persona 4 like
its predecessors persona 5 is part
social simulator part dungeon crawler by
day your normal everyday high school
student busy taking classes and hanging
out with friends but by night you are
the leader of the Phantom thieves a
ragtag troupe of idealistic teenagers
that infiltrate a parallel reality
called the meta verse here the corrupted
hearts of adults have manifested as
palaces and the Phantom thieves must
find and steal treasures within them to
reform their marks and by extension
society together with your friends you
infiltrate the meta verse where personas
physical representations of people's
personalities are used to fight with
elemental attacks exploiting a weakness
elevates battles from turn-based
slapsies to a flurry of crushing combos
hitting an enemy's weakness will give
you an additional turn and once they're
all keeled over you can launch an
all-out attack and watch as they are
sliced and diced until they burst into a
shower of blood even though you see it
hundreds of times it never stops being
cool
[Music]
compare the combat in persona 5 pulls
together some of the best elements from
previous games and has been streamlined
into an experience that sings
negotiations from early shin megami
tensei and persona games add another
satisfying wrinkle after downing enemies
you can demand items money or a monsters
allegiance for what you get depends on
your gift of the gab this rework system
let me reap the benefits I needed at
that point in my playthrough while
grinding I'd used an all-out attack to
earn more XP in a pinch I demand an item
it's much more useful than persona 3 in
fours random pickings from shuffle time
the palaces are the best dungeons the
series has ever had they are intricate
striking locations that unravel as you
explore them each varying in size scope
and gameplay opportunities one is a rat
maze filled with locked doors and
looping hallways another is a giant safe
that you need to crack and one is a
crumbling pyramid filled with walking
mummies they feel almost like different
worlds from a Mario game each uniquely
themed and cycling through gameplay
ideas like cards in a rolodex as phantom
thieves you sneak through holes darting
between cover and jumping over obstacles
before ambushing an unsuspecting enemy
and it feels really satisfying when it
works although you're encouraged to take
enemies now sneakily doing so is made
difficult by the game's uncooperative
camera which often restricts your view
while in stealth as a result clambering
over obstacles is unnecessarily finicky
while I find myself accidentally darting
headfirst into a shadow far too often
because the camera betrayed me at the
last second persona 5 has a hefty run
time and while enemies feel well matched
for the majority the gameplay has some
pacing issues towards the end
insta-kill attacks combined with long
stretches of mini boss after mini boss
without a save point mean that the
latter stages can sometimes feel more
frustrating than enjoyable
I've been wiped out half an hour into a
fight on multiple occasions and to be
honest I'm still a little bit bitter but
palaces are just one part of the meta
verse for those that enjoy the grind as
mementos societies joint palace which
takes the
one of Tokyo's subway system this area
is long with many procedurally generated
levels spiralling down towards a
mysterious seemingly unreachable core it
will feel like a monotonous job were it
not for the fan site a website where
members of the public can leave messages
of support or means fansite users can
suggest people they think deserve a
change of heart these are figures that
aren't quite evil enough to have their
own palace but who are still misbehaving
enough to spawn a mini-boss within
mementos these slide stories are mere
tasters bite-sized chunks of justice
that you can dull out to your leisure
while grinding for experience
[Music]
personified creates a rewarding synergy
between its social simulator and
dungeon-crawling by making everyday
activities in the former empower you in
the latter with limited time in each day
and a constant deadline to steal
treasures by it's up to the player to
prioritize after-school and weekend
activities character attributes such as
knowledge proficiency and guts can be
improved by studying working in
part-time jobs or watching DVDs in turn
these enable you to build deeper bonds
with other characters to strengthen
yourself and your cause persona games
live and die on characterization as much
as the RPG mechanics that underpin the
gameplay and in that respect the latest
entry delivers a cast that is lovable
quirky and nuanced in equal measure I
will put my heart and soul into creating
the best nude painting ever what
although the main group neatly fits into
classic anime archetypes initially over
time everyone reveals the baggage they
carry and your affection for them grows
as a result I love that you really had
to invest time and effort into each
character to crack their personality and
work through their pain together these
characters including my favorites
Morgana
the treasure obsessed talking amnesiac
cat and Futaba a hacker with extreme
social anxiety grow and change as you
spend more time with them going from
mechanical tools that you engage with to
strengthen their personas to real people
that you can identify and sympathize
with by the time the credits rolled I
felt like I was leaving behind friends
I'd known for years I heard that real
G's pretty much failed his exams Oh Mona
you little more than any entry in this
series before at persona 5 manages to
make the mundane not only an essential
part of its gameplay loop but also fun
at the same time Atlas has perfected the
back-and-forth investment and reward
dynamic between the games two parts the
real world and the Metaverse to a point
where even doing laundry is gratifying
and how many games can you say that
about
[Music]
persona 5 deals with complex subject
matter and really doesn't shy away from
dark even uncomfortable story beats a
constant theme of the game is oppression
and injustice using personal hardships
and the pressures of modern-day society
to explore how the actions of the older
generation affect the future of the
youth but there's also an optimism to it
all it's cast approaches intricate
issues with a clarity and gusto that can
only be born from teenaged naivety and
there's a refreshing and cathartic
quality to being part of that narrative
Lee Anne thematically persona 5 has the
potential to overwhelm but the writing
does a fantastic job of eliminating
unnecessary exposition to make sure the
important story arcs are clear and that
everyone is on the same page even with
the heavy subject matter little jokes
and Easter eggs mean the mood never
becomes overbearing at every turn
persona 5 presents something to marvel
at whether it's the fluid combat vibrant
world or the many memorable characters
it's a game that I could continue to
talk about for hours I haven't mentioned
the ability to connect to the Thieves
Guild and see how other players spent
their day or the thumping acid jazz
infused soundtrack that I've not been
able to get out of my head but I just
encapsulate why persona 5 is a game that
shouldn't be missed it's stopped a
bursting point with interesting
mechanics and presentation flourishes
there's an overwhelming level of
artistry poured into every part of it
bacon persona 5 a truly landmark entry
in the series it's a refined
effortlessly stylish RPG that will be
talked about for years to come
[Music]
you